I didn't feel like I had a lot of
respect would you want to be a serious
actress I have a serious actress
I had to make a career out of the pieces
left but I'm not the Damsel in Distress
I put myself in Crazy situations
and
survived them
I think that what I why I wanted to tell
my story too is I sure there's a lot of
people out there like me that have gone
through things in their childhood and
just haven't resolved that yet and I
really did the work it's hard hard work
but it's so rewarding when I saw those
videos I got so emotional because I
thought
that was it that was my time to really
be in love
right now I feel like it's almost like
I'm looking for something
well baby it looks so beautiful and I
really don't know where I'm gonna go
next I feel Restless
I'm looking for a feeling I can't find
it's difficult to go back into those
chapters of your life and feel those
feelings and for me to move home was
Full Circle but I was there like I'd
always say the trees have known me since
birth and I get chills talking about it
because I feel like it was just
difficult really painful thing to do but
I feel so free now I feel like the
weight of the world is off my shoulders
so I had to kind of put all the pieces
together saying this is my whole life
it's not just a red bathing suit or a
pink fuzzy hat you know I've gotten
through a lot of things in my own kind
of fun way and I now I think it makes
sense so I was trying to be as honest
and dig for those words that are the
hardest ones to say because when they're
hard to say that's what you need to say
so it's been a it's been a journey and
I'm loving it because it's pushing me
challenging me
[Music]